all right very very good hatred mail
this week if you've never heard hatred
mail before here's what hatred mail is
because the government that is
supposedly totally inept is the same
government that can pull off a
conspiracy that'll blow your mind
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom this weeks hey treat
male has within it a possible new slogan
for the David Pakman show someone a
couple weeks ago wrote in or posted
somewhere I think maybe on the subreddit
the David Pakman show needs some kind of
slogan that progressive provocative and
political or whatever it is that we have
on intro that it's no good and that we
need something new this hatred mail may
have such a new slogan for us let's take
a listen any mention of geoengineering
over course not there never is they are
spraying more than ever M sick of
baby-faced gags Pakman hey Pakman are
you being paid by George Soros because
isn't at other explanations David Pakman
giving Jews a bad name since 1984 and
Hispanics too all at once imagine if
that became the slogan of the David
Pakman show the David Pakman show
giving Jews a bad name since 1984 and
Hispanic do I think if we are gonna go
in this direction and transition to that
slogan for the show the and Hispanics
too is an absolutely crucial element of
that slogan yeah and if the hatred is
learning interested in learning more
about geoengineering I would refer him
to our February 2017 interview with
David Keith
yes that's do with chemtrails Matt
doesn't have to deal with climate change
mitigation yes indeed and at you know
the geoengineering thing when we I
interviewed at chemtrails conspiracy
theorists a couple years ago his name's
Dane Wigington
we reran that interview like in the last
I want to say three months or so and it
led to a deluge of chemtrails conspiracy
theorists writing stuff like this to me
so that's sort of the MD
catalyst for this message give a middle
finger to the hey tree 'it's by using
the coupon code hey tree at 40 when you
sign up at join pakman.com it'll save
you 40% and 3 hey tree 'it's will cry
every time that that coupon code is used